we're told that the weights of 11
different babies are recorded in the on
the line plot below and we see there's 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 data points each
one represents a different baby who's
whose weight is recorded each weight was
rounded to the nearest 1/8 of a pound
all right then they ask us what is the
difference in weight between the two
heaviest babies so pause this video and
try to figure that out before we work
through it together all right now where
are the two heaviest babies so this one
out here this is the heaviest baby and
what is its weight well let's see its
weight is right over there and what is
that number or what is that weight so
this is 9 and this is 10 and we have 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 equal spaces so each of
these is 1/8 so this is 9 and 1 2 9 and
2 8
so this one is let me write this this is
9 and 2 eights another way to think
about it is 2 eights is the same thing
as 1/4 because if you think about it is
1 2 3 4 equal spaces this is also 9 and
1/4 of the way to 10 so this is the same
thing as 9 and 1/4 and then what's the
second heaviest babies because we want
the weight difference between the two
heaviest so the second heaviest baby is
right over here and we know that it is 8
and 1/2 pounds so what we really need to
do is figure out what is the difference
between 9 and 2 8 or 9 and 1/4 and eight
and a half right over here so we could
set this up as a subtraction this is
going to be 9 and let's call it 9 and
1/4 minus minus 8 and 1/2 and we can
actually use this this these measurement
scales or you can even do this is
something of a number line to help us
think about this the difference is this
length right over here and we could
think about it in terms of eighths
because each of these hash
in eighth so 1/8 2/8 3/8 4/8 5/8 and 6/8
so this is equal to 6/8 we could also
think about it in terms of fourths so
this is 1/4 2/4 and 3/4 so this is equal
to 3/4 so what's the difference in
weight between the two heaviest babies
it is 3/4 of a pound